How can I remain silent,
when what we have seen for over 15 years,
not even a surgeon can get used to?
How can I remain silent,
when we know that these crimes against humanity
have been planned with a purely economic motive?
There are few days when the news in my region
isn't linked to a new human tragedy.
Last week, more than 50 people were massacred
with machetes in Beni territory, North Kivu.
Pregnant women are cut open
and babies mutilated.
Women's bodies have become a real battlefield
and rape is used as a weapon of war.
Even a single case of rape is serious
and requires action from all of us.
In my country,
hundreds of thousands of women have been raped.
I think of every woman who has been raped
as my wife,
of every mother who has been raped
as my mother,
and of every child who has been raped
as my children.
In a world which has lost its values,
where violence is trivialised with impunity,
refusing violence is to be a dissident.
By drawing the world's attention
to the need to protect women during armed conflict,
you have refused to remain indifferent
to one of the greatest humanitarian disasters of modern times.
There can be neither peace
nor economic and social progress
without respect for human rights.
Today, Europe is expressing its solidarity to us
loud and clear and in front of the whole world.
It wants to walk with us in our quest
for the restoration of a dignified Congolese life.
Our country is sick,
but together with our friends around the world
we can and we will heal it.
Thank you.